the climate emergency is the defining
crisis of our time we are in a race
against time and we are losing there is
a growing tide of impatience especially
among young people with global inaction
we need more ambition from all
governments cities businesses investors
and people everywhere so I'm pleased you
are launching Ted countdown your
influence and ideas can help accelerate
momentum for a carbon-neutral world by
2050 that is the only way to avert the
worst impacts of global heating we have
the tools the science and resources let
us now get into this race with political
will and energy to do anything less will
be a betrayal of our entire human family
and generations to come thank you and
now please welcome one of the architects
of the Paris climate agreement
Christiana Figueres and the head of Ted
Chris Anderson
welcomewelcome something remarkable it's
going to happen in the next hour the
world's single most alarming challenge
which looks something like this is about
to go head-to-head with some of the
world's most amazing minds and
courageous hearts which looks something
like you the extraordinary audience we
have here in New York and around the
world
Christiana is quite the crowd we get to
hang out with this morning sure is no
kidding
it's a good thing that everyone is here
together because actually this
initiative that we're just about to
watch needs everyone to participate and
here it is countdown countdown is a
global initiative to cut greenhouse gas
emissions it's seeking bold solutions in
five big areas imagining what could be
achieved if different groups broke out
of their silos and acted together
starting today you can go to countdown
dead calm and sign up to join the
countdown early in 2020 will be sharing
plans on how you can connect with others
in your company or city or your school
to engage in this issue it's all leading
up to global gatherings on 1010 2020
everyone in the world is invited to
participate and so that's why although
I've been part of many initiatives along
the years I'm really excited about this
one because countdown is an invitation
to everyone everyone to play their part
in saving our planet and creating an
exciting future politicians and citizens
CEOs and their customers their employees
their investors
old and young north and south I see what
you did there
felucca our goal is not to plunge in
with something new that is competitive
with the amazing initiatives already out
there no it's it's to identify the best
solutions that have already been worked
on to cross-fertilize them to amplify
them
and then activate them by bringing
together these different groups and if
that happens we believe there is a way
out of the climate crisis that's what we
want to facilitate but now Chris
question why are you and Ted interested
in participating and actually activating
the climate agenda what I thought you
were all about spreading ideas well
indeed that has been our focused mission
for the last 15 years ideas were
spreading but last summer we concluded
that the urgency of some issues and
especially climate demanded that we try
to do more than just spread ideas that
we actually try to activate them now
we're just a relatively small nonprofit
that would not amount to anything if we
fail to bring other people on board but
the amazing thing is that that has
happened everyone we've spoken to about
this has got excited about participating
and one of the key moments frankly was
when you came on board
christiana I mean you were key to the
Paris agreement and the world was
stunned at the consensus that emerged
there what was the key to creating that
consensus I would say it was to really
challenge and change people's assumption
about what is possible if we set a
shared intention and then collectively
pursue it and achieve it so our mantra
then and continues to be impossible is
not a fact it's an attitude in fact only
an attitude and that is something we can
change
well that mantra is something we're
going to have to hold on to in the
months ahead because the scientific
consensus is actually worsening for a
quick report from the front lines here's
the head of the thousands of scientists
who make up the IPCC doctor who Sangli
we recently released three special
reports
they show a damage and risks of past and
future climate change they also show
that stabilizing climate would implies a
drastic reduction of greenhouse gas
emissions in the near term the Society
will have to go through unprecedented
changes to meet this goal even limiting
warming to 1.5 degrees Celsius will
bring more extreme weather rising sea
levels and water shortages in some
regions and threat to food security and
biodiversity higher temperature will
bring more of these damages threatening
lives and livelihoods of millions of
people all around the world well I could
have with us another world leading
scientist Johan Rock Strom here he was
responsible for creating the planetary
boundaries framework Johan how serious
is our situation last week we released
in nature the ten year update of the
risk of crossing tipping points
irreversible tipping points in the earth
system we know 15 such tipping points
including Greenland and West Antarctic
ice shelf and the permafrost and the
Siberian tundra for example and we today
have observational evidence I mean
empirical evidence that nine of the 15
have woken up and are on the move they
haven't crossed the tipping point yet
the window is still open but they are
warning us that now is the time to truly
move because the moment we cross them
like for example approaching a tipping
point in the Amazon rainforest we would
risk losing the battle because the
planet will be taking over its cell-free
fourth warming so that is why this
initiative is so incredibly important
let's go well said so both are very
clear there that this agenda of cutting
emissions is absolutely crucial how has
that been going
not very well because despite what we
know despite everything the science has
told us despite everything that we have
done including adopting the Paris
agreement we've actually been increasing
greenhouse gases consistently over the
past few decades to the point where
we're now at 50
five Giga tons of carbon dioxide
equivalent that we are collectively as
humanity emitting every year and as we
have heard we have a one path there is
one path that we have to follow and that
is start now to decrease emissions
instead of going up go down reverse the
trend bend the curve reduce emissions
starting in 2020 to the point where we
will be one-half the current level of
emissions by 2030 and then continue
decreasing them until we are at Net Zero
by 2050 it's the only part that we can
accept I mean how do you even begin to
start tackling that goal as daunting as
that well we could start by breaking the
simple yet daunting challenge into its
constituent pieces five main areas and
so these these five together are
actually they're all huge and if you can
find compelling solutions in each of
them they would actually add up to an
action plan that is that matches the
scale of the problem well here are the
five power how rapidly can we move to a
hundred percent clean energy a built
environment how can we re engineer the
stuff that surrounds us transport how do
we transform the ways we move ourselves
and goods food how can we spark a
worldwide shift to healthier food
systems and certainly nature how
extensively can we regrain the earth now
it's worth noting that the answers to
these questions and the measures that we
would undertake don't just reduce net
emissions they do that certainly
together to zero but they also point the
way to a future that is much better and
genuinely exciting so think about cool
new forms of transport
clean air healthier food beautiful
forests and oceans bursting with life so
you know solving the climate crisis
isn't about sacrificing and settling for
mediocre future it's about the exact
opposite
it's about co-creating a much better
future for all of us so how do we call
these questions let's take let's take
this question here and think about this
how extensively can we grow in the earth
I mean they're obviously many responses
to this question and many proposals is
fundamentally about how do we increase
the amount of sustainable photosynthesis
on planet earth photosynthesis
sequester's carbon they're going to be
proposals around giant kelp forests or
seagrass or about forms of plants that
have deeper roots and can sequester
across the planet but suppose a major
proposal that came out was about
reforestation a massive global
reforestation campaign I mean a single
organization no matter how big cannot
take that on
the key is for everyone to join forces
for governments with Zoning businesses
to invest investors to do that investing
environmental groups and philanthropists
who support them and just a massive
movement among citizens everywhere
transforming their lawns their cities
their neighborhoods going on trips
together that is where suddenly you can
dream about something really big so can
we test that theory because we are
fortunate to have with us today someone
who grew up inside a tree planting
movement probably the most well
recognized tree planting movement and
she is the daughter of the Nobel Prize
winner one Gary Matai and she heads up
the one Gary Matai foundation today so
can we invite our very dear friend one
Jairam Atty
thank you very much thank you very much
mr. Chris for doing this trees have been
indeed a part of my life for as long as
I can remember but we also know that for
centuries trees and forests have
cushioned us against the harsh impacts
of climate variation for very many years
in my lifetime my mother through the
green belt movement as you mentioned
inspired the planting of 50 million
trees and Counting through the work of
the green belt movement one organization
but the world now needs us to plant a
hundred times more trees than we did
then and the only way to do that is for
all of us to come together cities
citizens governments companies
environmental organizations and we must
believe therefore in the capacity for
each of us to be potent agents of change
and that together we are a force and I
hope you will all join us put together
we are a force I think we're here when
it hits it right there on the head
because it's all about collaborating
across a pretty broad spectrum of people
and happily there are representatives
from all of those groups here today and
we will be inviting you toward further
engagement but we wanted today to
introduce you to a couple of those
people speaking from their own
perspective so we would like to start
with the voice of a politician we are
incredibly honored to have with us today
the former prime minister of Bhutan and
I will have you know the Bhutan is the
only country in the world that actually
absorbs more carbon than what it admits
our good friend sharing top guy
my country is typical of the global
South in that we have not caused this
climate change crisis
indeed we are blessed with lush forests
and many bountiful rivers that has
enabled my country Bhutan to remain
carbon negative and yet
climate change threatens to destroy our
forests and to turn those very rivers
into terrible dangers for our people as
the Himalayan glaciers melt and threaten
both near-term flooding and the
longer-term loss of a natural water
reserves so I am proud to join this
countdown initiative and work with all
of you and with you and with you
constructively to find solutions that
are both powerful and just thank you
business of course has a crucial role to
play and so do those who controlled the
world's vast pools of investment capital
I was pleased to make the acquaintance
recently of the chief investment officer
of Japan's 1.6 trillion dollar
government pension fund it's actually
the world's largest pension fund he's
willing and interested to come with us
on this journey and to bring others with
him so somewhere is I believe hero hero
hero and your life welcome here right
thanks Chris and Christiana
and the staff of Ed or making this
possible as a person in charge of the
largest pension fund in the world and a
responsible securing a pension for
multiple generations this is hugely
important if you help manage I'm at risk
we recently analyzed a global portfolio
how it's aligned with Paris agreement
it was diagnosed our portfolios on the
past for more than three degrees far
away from Paris agreement Rose a
portfolio is not only sizable but also
one of the most globally diversified
portfolio so that means world is on that
path
I'm tired of hearing the same comment
repeatedly from our portfolio companies
and obviously investment professional we
are realistic sorry but being realistic
is no longer an option
we free our as the world largest asset
owner to inspire change in a capital
market will be actively engaging with
all actors in a capital market to move
the needle I look forward to
participating in this crucial dialogue
with you all thank you I'm sure all of
you know that throughout the past 12 to
18 months what has really been new and
powerful and exciting is the amazing
voices of so many young people millions
of young people who are out there on the
streets with anger with outrage with
despair and also asking us to do our
thing
and they have been inspired by Greta
Sundberg but by so many other fantastic
young people in almost every country of
the world and today we are delighted to
have four young activists come join us
today
this Friday
I'll have been on climate strike for 52
weeks that's an entire year during that
time I found that many people don't know
about climate change or how serious the
climate crisis is so I found it earth
apprising international to teach young
people about climate change because when
they know the science and the impacts
they want to take action being an
activist means making change happen I
became a climate activists because my
life depends on it I'm applying to
colleges right now trying to plan for my
future but there will be nothing to look
forward to if we don't take urgent
action to stop the climate crisis now I
started the youth climate justice
movement called zero hour back in 2017
because this is zero hour to act on
climate change we have no more time it
became clear to me that our leaders were
not going to take real action unless the
people stood up and demanded it so
that's exactly what we did I became a
climate justice activist because if I
don't fight for the rights of the people
today and for the people in the future
who will I became a climate justice
activist when I realized that the
climate crisis impacts marginalized
communities the most including my town
in Mexico I strike with Friday's per
feature every Friday because our
movement is not about gaining momentum
but about igniting cultural change but
the fact that thousands of students
strike for climate means that we are
already implementing climate justice
into every aspects of our lives which is
already really finding the world over
the course of our lifetimes we have seen
the earth deteriorate at a rapid speed
and groups of people traumatized and
displaced by an ever increasing number
of natural disasters in 2030 I'll be 28
years old I'll be 24 years old I will be
27 I'll be 26 we want to be able to hand
the planet over to our children and our
children's children just like many of
you have been able to do so unless
everyone governments
companies schools scientists and
citizens make a united commitment to
reversing the damage that we've caused
it will be too late we are not only
asking you to take care of our future
we're also asking you to take care of
our past
indigenous people having taken care of
the earth for thousands of years
which is why indigenous philosophy is
crucial when implementing climate action
this climate crisis can feel like an
impossible thing to fix but it's not and
it can't be because failure is simply
not an option failure means losing
everything we love and everything that
matters so many of us are already
working to save the future of our world
but it can't just be on the next
generation to fix this is too much of a
burden to just put on young people's
shoulders it is time for you to go all
hands on deck and do everything within
your power to save everything before
it's too late
are you with us
thank you thank you thank you and then
of course there's a crucial role to be
played by the world's storytellers and
those with influence on social media
platforms each of the following has
expressed excitement to be part of this
project they've lent us their names and
support we have some of them here today
thank you so much for being here
and let's hear from one of them actually
hi I'm Jimmy Kimmel and I was asked to
explain why I'm passionate about climate
change
and the reason I'm passionate about
climate change is the same reason people
who are drowning or passionate about
lifeguards I care about this planet
because I live on it I don't want to
move to Mars Mars seems terrible I want
my kids and their kids to be able to
live on Earth with air they can breathe
and water they can drink that's why I
care about climate change and also I
have a crush on Leonardo DiCaprio we
have an opportunity to explore a new
space of possibility for solutions based
on working together challenging each
other and inspiring one another so in
October next year we will be inviting
less a thousand people from different
constituencies to meet in Bergen Norway
to align on specific answers to our five
big questions it will certainly be an
epic event but even more significant
than what happens in Norway is what
happens elsewhere in the world because
on the final day of that conference
we're planning a major activation of our
global TEDx community TEDx allows
initiatives to organize local events and
there are now four thousand such events
annually here's what they look like they
take place in more than 200 different
countries generate more than a billion
views annually on YouTube we're
expecting to see events therefore in
hundreds of cities we'll be connecting
our TEDx organizers with city mayors
committed to a clean future
for their cities this is the key to this
it's this connection between the
powerful who usually own the
conversation and millions of people
around the world that because of the
zeitgeist shift that's happened in the
last year or two
suddenly ignition can happen here
because there's enough critical
groundswell if we can give people
visibility of each other connection to
each other let's dream a little here and
give each other permission to dream so
our goal here is to build connections
with and among all of the other
organizations that are working on
climate for example the solutions
project is a wonderful initiative
founded by Mark Ruffalo and Don chill
and let's hear from some of the leaders
that they have supported welcome your
life my name is Mihaly John's I'm with
native renewables and we are working to
provide solar power for tribes
throughout the world we have over 15,000
Native American families that don't have
access to electricity and we are working
to provide solar plus battery storage
for these families in the United States
that don't have access to electricity
and they are located on my reservation
the Navajo Nation and the hi everyone I
am an Allah pain with real food media
and we worked new uplift the stories of
farmers and ranchers as a key solution
to the climate crisis the global food
system right now is a huge contributor
to this crisis but it doesn't have to be
farmers and ranchers we really see as on
the front lines of being part of solving
the crisis so we try to share the
stories of the millions of farmers from
Andhra Pradesh India to the highlands of
Oaxaca that are using regenerative
agriculture to build healthy carbon rich
soil grow good food and foster the kind
of resilient communities that we need
hello from push Buffalo my name is rawa
where every day residents are visioning
planning and designing an equitable
holistic and sacred neighborhood like
where I'm pointing
from school 77 a renovated vacant school
building that has the first 100%
affordable community solar array in New
York State installed by local residents
it's also serving 30 affordable senior
apartments and a mix of intergeneric
intergenerational spaces that serves as
a community hub where we're practicing
new economy strategies towards a livable
planet thank you so you see this is
about everyone
it's about cities it's about grassroots
organizations but it's also of course
about business and so we're inviting all
companies underlying all to join this
initiative to engage with your employees
on how you can best protect the planet
and your future at the same time so
early next year we'll be sharing a
toolkit that can guide companies toward
moving quickly toward science-based
targets which gets them then to net zero
emissions by 2050 at the latest so think
about this because as an individual many
individuals feel powerless on this issue
but if you were to team up with others
in your company you might be amazed at
how much power you actually have almost
all emissions come from a company
somewhere on the planet and the thing is
many CEOs today are actually eager to
help solve the problem
we just heard this morning from Anand
Mahindra who heads India's biggest
business group that he is personally
committed on this issue and wants to be
part of this journey with us he's a
supporter of countdown CEOs will be able
to move much faster if there's a group
of employees there to brainstorm with to
support them to keep that sort of sense
of urgency on the topic so look on our
website we'll help you connect with
others in your company and give you
guidance on smart
to ask initiatives to suggest because if
companies can't be persuaded to do the
right thing suddenly this problem seems
to become solvable so all of these
efforts are building toward one
fantastic day Saturday October 10 2020
that is 10 10 20 20 easy to remember
when this fantastic gathering will take
place around the world and we hope to
have by that thrilling news of the
report of the very specific solutions
that nation's cities companies citizens
are actually already collaborating on by
then it's a day when every citizen of
the planet is invited to participate
your one ticket of entrance is you are a
citizen of the planet key to the success
of the event is to fit for this to
happen at scale I mean we want to make
it easy for anyone and everyone to find
out about the initiative and to play an
active part in it but how do you do that
you know the world's a noisy place I
mean the TED platform can help a bit
maybe but there's a much bigger content
platform out there it's called YouTube
and we're delighted to be working with
them on this endeavor we'll be inviting
many of their top creators to be part of
countdown collectively they could reach
an audience in the many millions and in
fact let's meet one of them dr.
Johansson of hot mess a new web series
about the impact of climate change on
all of us my name is Joe Hansen and I am
a youtube educator and you can count me
in I work with tomorrow's scientists
inventors and leaders and they deserve
to know the truth of what the science
says so that they can help us invent a
better future for everyone
imagine that multiplied by many others
it's very very exciting honestly and of
course when it comes to spreading the
word every one of you in this room can
actually play your part so if you have
any way of reaching anyone who is
turned about building a better future
and that should be every single one of
us please invite them to join countdown
there's one more card up our sleeve
we're excited to unveil a global media
campaign this is a campaign with a
difference
just as TEDx exploded by being allowed
to grow as a grassroots phenomenon so
you know this campaign is designed to be
co-opted everywhere on the planet if you
happen to own a billboard company or a
TV station or a radio station or a
website or a social media account we
invite all of you to take the images
you're about to see and to just spread
them far and wide our website will make
this easy we actually plan to translate
them into many languages courtesy of our
volunteer army of more than 20,000
translators worldwide some of them are
with us here if you're a TED translator
would you wave please young your work
carries powerful ideas to every corner
of the earth we're so proud of you so
grateful to you
so this campaigns designed to grab
attention and to communicate yes urgency
but also a little smidgen of hope we
think it might be that combination is
what is needed to really drive action
would love you to let us know what you
think of these right now
[Applause]
I see I didn't like the song but my team
you know now that's really powerful this
is unfortunately unfortunately truer
than you know and that's it okay
to bring this full circle we would like
to bring someone very special in hi I'm
Claire O'Neill I am the president
designate for next year's conference of
the parties the annual UN climate change
talks which will be in the UK and we're
looking forward to welcoming you there
but right now I'm in Spain in Madrid at
Kop 25 this annual event where we send
negotiators and activists more over the
world to see what we can do to reduce
co2 emissions but the problem is this
emissions are going up not down
and what I am feeling is that 2020 is
the year of action the year where we
have to stop talking or we have to start
acting and not just here in these
conference centres but everybody and so
the value of the dead process the value
of what we're all doing together is that
we're spreading out the conversations
and the solutions from inside this space
out to everybody and I'm really looking
forward to working with the Tempur over
the next year 2020 for me will be the
most important year for climate action
very first a word from one of the many
great minds who will be accompanying us
on this journey a message from the great
author historian and futurist you all
Harare climate change is about
inequality inequality between the rich
who are mainly responsible for it and
the poor who will suffer the most
inequality between us Homo sapiens who
control this planet and the other
animals who are our helpless victims
inequality between the scientists who
painstakingly search for the truth and
the professional deceivers who spread
falsehoods at the click of a button
climate change is about making a choice
what kind of planet do we want to
inhabit and what kind of humans do we
want to be a choice between greed and
compassion between carelessness and
responsibility between clothes
our eyes to the truth and opening our
hearts to the world climate change is a
crisis but for humans a crisis is always
also an opportunity if we make the right
choices in the coming years we can not
only save the ecosystem but we can also
create a more just world and make
ourselves better people so isn't that a
powerful framing of what we have ahead
of us and honestly I think it is tragic
that the power of transformation that we
have ahead of us is so severely
diminished by those who would want to
politicize the issue and separated into
partisan of politics it cannot be a
partisan issue it cannot be a
politicized issue happily there are some
who are working against that today we
have one of those people and a
fantastically courageous climate
scientist who is a committed Christian
and who has been working on this issue
with conservatives and with the
religious and spiritual communities for
years with incredible courage Katharine
Hayhoe
sermon says climate change we often
think oh that's just an environmental
issue people who are tree huggers are
scientists care about it or maybe people
who are on the left-hand side of the
political spectrum but the reality is
whether we know it or not
we already care about climate change no
matter who we are why because climate
change affects everything we already
care about today it affects our health
it affects the food we eat the water we
drink the air that we breathe climate
change affects the economy and national
security I care about a changing climate
because it is as the military calls it a
threat multiplier it takes issues like
poverty and hunger disease lack of
access to clean water even political
instability and exacerbates or amplifies
them that's why to care about a changing
climate we don't have to be a certain
type of person a thermometer isn't blue
red liberal or conservative it gives us
the same number no matter how we vote
and we are all affected by the impacts
of a changing climate
so to care about a changing climate all
we have to be is one thing a human
living on planet earth and we're all
that the man who brought this issue so
powerfully to everyone's attention years
ago and has continued tirelessly to work
on that issue ever since the one and
very only Al Gore thank you thank you so
much Christiana and thank you for your
outstanding leadership and thank you
Chris Anderson and the entire Ted
community youtube and all of the others
who are joining in this fantastic
initiative I have just three one this
crisis is incredibly urgent just
yesterday the scientists gave us the
report that emissions are still going up
every single day we're putting a hundred
million tons of manmade global warming
pollution into the thin shell of
atmosphere surrounding our planet the
accumulated amount now traps as much
extra energy every day as would be
released by 500,000 first generation
atomic bombs exploding every single day
again the consequences are increasingly
clear all that mother nature is telling
us that the fires of the sea level rise
and the floods and the mudslides and the
loss of living species but the second
message that I have is the hope is very
real we actually do have the solutions
available to us it is unfortunately true
at this moment that the crisis is
getting worse faster than we are
mobilizing these solutions but renewable
energy and electric vehicles and
batteries and regenerative accurate
circular manufacturing and all of these
other solutions are gaining momentum the
late economist root
Dornan Bush in articulating what's known
as Dorn Bush's law said things to things
take longer to happen than you think but
then they happen much faster than you
thought they could we can pick up the
pace we are gaining momentum and soon we
will be gaining on the crisis but it is
essential that everyone join of every
political persuasion every ideological
persuasion every nationality every
division has to be obliterated so that
we humanity can join together and in
closing I would just say that for anyone
who doubts that we as human beings have
the ability to rise to this occasion
when everything is on the line just
remember that political will is itself a
renewable resource
thank you so much thank you so much our
for your leadership on this issue for so
many years none of this would be
possible without an extraordinary and
fast growing list of partners I'd like
to acknowledge them if you're watching
this you believe your organization
should be part of this you can help in
some way join us
email me Kris at Ted calm this is going
to take everyone okay before the Q&A I
just want to ask you a question
personally Christiana like what what do
you really think you've no know you've
been in so many of these does this
initiative have a chance well first of
all we're at the point where everything
place everything place and I'm really
excited about this because it has been
very painful to me to see how over the
past 12 to 18 months because of the
tragically insufficient response that we
have had to climate change how that
zeitgeist has been changing from where
we were in Paris which was pretty
positive and optimistic to now despair
helplessness anger that's what is out
there roaming on the streets I don't
blame them and I have the same feelings
but the point is we have to be able to
transform that into making the
difference and I think what this is this
initiative is actually potentially ready
to do which is to give every single
person who feels helpless give them a
tool to do something some will
contribute small efforts some will
contribute large Ivor's depends on what
your influence area is and to those who
feel angry and and and despairing well
give them also an opportunity to channel
that energy which is very powerful
energy into solutions and finally what
is very exciting about this is the scale
Chris right I mean just look at those
are those
partners that are going to be there we
have attempted many many things to bring
to scale but this I think is the most
promising initiative that I have seen to
be able to bring people to scale to
bring efforts and solutions to scale and
speed because if there's one thing that
we cannot cannot fail on is addressing
climate change but not only that to do
so in a timely way thank you
that is eloquent and thank you that's it
okay we have many members of the the
world's leading media here we're going
to have a Q&A they should probably have
priority on questions if it all goes
deathly silent someone else can ask the
question if your if you remember the
media here please feel free to put your
hand up we'll throw a mic to you and
we'll do the best we can hi Rachel crane
from CNN my question for you is about
more specific action that will come out
of countdown we heard a lot today about
how this is mobilizing the globe on this
issue breaking people out of their silos
companies out of their silos but I'm
curious to know paint a picture for us
of what that the action that will come
out of this initiative could potentially
look like I'm sure you know it's all in
early phases we won't hold you
specifically to this there's an intense
process going on between now and October
where we're trying to engage all of the
world's best thinking on climate around
those five big areas what we're hoping
to have there is multiple proposals in
there that collectively take a huge bite
out of those issues some of them there
may be one big one that that dominates
now so transport for example could we
accelerate the end of the internal
combustion engine somehow what would
that take that that would be a classic
problem made for this approach because
what governments decide right now
depends on what they see happening
elsewhere would the decisions of auto
executives be shifted if they saw
millions of people on social media
saying I will never buy a combustion
engine would they be shifted by the
it's signal of a few hundred mares is
saying we are creating a carbon zero
zone in our city and we're going to
expand it and we're doing that soon
would they be shifted by a visionary
auto CEO taking the risk in coming
forward and saying you know when we said
we were going to continue this till 2050
no we can see the writing on the wall we
want to be on the right side of history
we're doing this in 2030 we think there
might be a pathway to that but it's so
on some of these issues is going to
depend on a massive amount of discussion
bringing people together showing this is
what you're so masterful at is showing
that other people don't have the
attitudes that you think they have
they're actually shifting you better
shift and it's so it's it's mutually
raising everyone's ambition level and
that that is that is a cycle that
happens in we've already seen it
happening and so on each of these issues
that's what we're looking for the
biggest boldest things dream bigger than
we normally do because there are more
people at the table than there normally
are ie millions of citizens engaged in
this that's the process and while that
is happening there'll be multiple other
engagements in companies and cities
around the world we hope that it all
comes together in a thrilling manner in
October and we have something to
celebrate my name is Dominic Drake Ford
with Mellon and ass or social media as a
form of media in understanding the
inherent correlation between the
cumulation of carbon in the atmosphere
and the cumulative exploitation and
extraction extractivism economy which
creates sacrifice zones for black and
indigenous communities how do we plan to
or how do you guys plan to mitigate
those systems of oppression as part of
your strategies within those five
various components so that we can really
begin to reduce emissions if the
transformation in our economy and our
society does not include inequality
closing and social justice issues then
we're doing nothing because all of those
things will come back to bite us
we have to put our arms around the
entire package that is not easy but it
is entirely possible and that's one of
the things that I'm so excited about
climate change because it is it it is at
the front of this transformation but it
will bring many of the other issues that
have been relegated to non attention it
will bring those issues to the fore as
well so the transformation has to be an
integrative transformation hi Chris hi
Christopher
my question is are individual efforts
like King plastic straws are going vegan
making a difference or ropes in the
ocean it's a good question
they are totally important absolutely
important because it's not just about
the one straw that I use it's about me
not using that straw going to a
restaurant and telling the waitress
excuse me I don't want a plastic straw
because and giving her a little us and
then she goes up to the manager manager
comes to the table and says excuse me
could you please explain that to me then
you go through the lesson and sooner you
know then you think you have that
restaurant plus the other one plus the
other one actually information is
contagious and wanting to do the right
thing is also contagious so don't look
at it as just simply you know what is
the straw am I using the straw or you
know am I not using plastic plastic bags
to do I have my my my plant-based hours
bags to go shopping etc etc all of that
counts it counts for you first of all
because it is a personal reminder of who
you are and what you stand for but it is
also a very important tool to educate
everyone around you right and I think
the core of our initiative is all that
stuff matters what you eat how you
transport yourself etc it matters a lot
but there is some there is another piece
of power that individuals have that they
don't think about as much perhaps and
that we think that they should we invite
them to which is what they can do as an
employee and what they
can do it as a member of a city there's
a coming together here where by getting
organized by connecting with others we
think there is a direct route to
changing decisions that will have an
even bigger impact on the problem so
it's it's yes all of that and but more
as well there is a um online promoter
children what can students do yeah I
love that question
totally love that question so first of
all Friday's 11 o'clock go strike I mean
honestly
right let's go let's go and and that
pressure has to be maintained
I'm totally delighted that you know
there are some people here who've been
here doing it for 52 weeks the problem
with this is folks this is not a sprint
it's a marathon so you better get ready
for many more 52 weeks right and get
more people involved because this is
going this is not easy if it were easy
we would have done it this is going to
be a long term effort but fantastic to
be out there in the streets you are
getting so much more attention from the
media from a stupid adults who have not
done our job
it is fantastic so you know get your
voices out there also in school you can
definitely go and improve take the
question that you just asked to Ted
that's the question that every student
should be asking their school where's my
energy coming from let's get with it
right students in in colleges how is it
possible that we still have colleges and
universities that I have that are not a
hundred percent clean energy and they
haven't shifted their all their capital
in their endowment over to low low
carbon I mean it's just incredible and
finally the most important thing that
young people can do is ask your parents
what the hell are you doing about my
future because here is an amazing thing
I have spoken and I'm I was thinking how
many I've spoken to at least three if
not four CEOs from the oil and gas
industry I've spoken to three or four
major investors heads of their
investment firms
who come up to me usually in private and
say Christiana the reason why I'm
changing what I do in my business is
because my daughter or my son asks me at
night what the hell are you doing about
my future that is a very powerful
question and only young people can ask
that question use that tool ask your
parents what are they doing about your
future sorry about the h-word hi I'm Joe
convener at the half post Cristiano a
question for you which is one of the
things that didn't come out so much in
this is about the spiritual traditions
and and the role they play in terms of
coz what we're seeing is that actually
old wisdom is coming out in terms of
interdependence nothing is separate from
anything else but is the spiritual
tradition we can bring to this that will
make also a difference what I think is
very powerful about understanding
whether you happen to be a spiritual
person that pursues meditation and
mindfulness or whether you're a
religious person or not what I think is
very powerful about the spiritual
understanding of the human presence on
this earth is to understand that we're
not separate
it's not like there's over there is
planet Earth and then humans are over
here and we are totally interconnected
with all other species and with all
other living beings and doing the
responsible thing by them does the
responsible thing by us and vice versa
and so that interconnectedness is one
that comes from the spiritual traditions
but you don't have to be religious or
spiritual to understand that you know
the fact is every single drop of water
that we drink comes from nature every
single morsel of food that we eat comes
from nature and we've got to heal that
connection we would welcome engagement
hi Kaylee Rosses from Women's Wear Daily
obviously the fashion industry is
responsible for a lot of the carbon
output so I wondered what is your
perspective on conscious consumption the
key goal here is to align at the same
time to change opinion and what
companies do what employees do what
consumers do you know it's it's it's the
pits the shifts all happening at the
same time that can make change right now
someone else is always the problem
our Vestas wouldn't allow us to do that
there is no market for this better more
sustainable product and so all the
pieces need to happen at the same time
that's our hope and so the lead on this
is not us its employees and CEOs and
leadership teams working in those in
that industry get together make make
something happen and ride the tide of
the zeitgeist shift that is happening
it's going to work out from a business
point of view as well can I jump on that
as well because for years for centuries
we have been on a consumer extract and
consume mentality right the way the way
we go about our life and the way that
businesses are created is extract use
discard extract use discard it's a
simplification but honestly it's as
simple as that and to understand that
that linear extraction to discard can no
longer be the case that it needs to be
circular now we have to go in to a
circular economy that uses every single
resource that we extract because we will
continue to extract that uses it not
once but two three four five ten times
around and around and around the circles
that's the circular economy and we have
to get to that point because frankly
we're running out of resources to
continue to extract hi my name is Jody
Shu crying I'm with the South China
Morning Post on Hong Kong publication
here in the US so we've been reporting
on trade war for more than a year and
we're actually living in a in a world
where countries are decoupling from each
other how do you overcome that try and
and bring everyone together
we don't know these are these are really
challenging issues what we do know is
that we have to bring everyone to the
table and have the discussion there are
so many people in China including in
many occasions the Chinese government
has has made bold steps to tackle this
issue there's a lot that the West can
learn from what's happening in China I
would say in a world in which we're
seeing a wave of nationalism and
populism the way we go at this is
actually to expand the breadth of
engagement so not to let the
responsibility of engaging on climate be
in national government hands only yes
they have an important role but we can
bring it down as well to a different
level of engagement with just every
single human being and once we
understand that we're all human beings
and that we all have a common future
there's no such thing as all of us being
in the boat and only the ones we're
closest to the hole in the boat are
going to sink No
well either we all sink or if we all
float together my name is Justine coma
I'm with the verge thanks so much for
this my question is about Ted and
YouTube's own carbon footprint a
streaming video eats up a huge amount of
energy and you know I'm curious what Ted
and YouTube might be doing to reduce
their own greenhouse gas emissions
connected to that I can't speak for
YouTube obviously I will say that to
quote a line from George mom Bo all of
us are hypocrites in this movement if
you've ever bought something or you're
wearing clothes or you know you're
eating food you know you're you're a
hypocrite you're you're creating
emissions it's part of life and I think
perfection is there's a risk that
perfection that the pursuit there's a
sort of an over pursuit and focus on
that and the judging that comes with it
can slow everyone down we want this to
be a Coalition of the Willing who accept
that they're not perfect but are willing
to act now this whole process has
sparked a huge conversation in Ted about
how we act more responsibly
and that will continue we're certainly
not going to stop streaming videos we
think at some point you have to do math
you know it's like that it's give to the
planet more than you take from it I
think is the is the golden rule that I
personally really believe in and so if
an idea you know powered by a little bit
of electricity can ignite in someone's
brain I would bet on the idea over
saving the electricity but there's no
perfection in this and and we definitely
have a lot that we need to improve on
let's go here and then back I'm lame
search I'm from The Wall Street Journal
magazine and Chris I really liked what
you were saying about the fashion
industry and what they can do to change
and how it requires employees and CEOs
to meet together because who understands
an industry better than the people in it
and their process is an infrastructure
but I'm wondering what about companies
with huge footprints and two that come
to mind first are Amazon and Zara where
by all accounts the workers the
employees there don't have very much
power and the CEOs don't have very much
incentive to change right now what what
would you say about those kinds of
companies so this is going to be such an
important conversation going forward
because we're in the ironic position
where the people who can do the most to
solve this problem are the people who
are currently the worst offenders so
what do we do do we make them part of
the conversation or not I say we make
them part of the conversation so long as
we see serious engagement so take Amazon
Jeff Bezos has actually listened to what
many of his employees have said they've
been very vigorous the employee base
they're about cover footprint has
listened has engaged with you and with
others and they they have announced I
think it's quite to say announced an
acceleration of their own commitment to
go to basically a Net Zero track by 2040
if I have it right it's the companies
with the thousands the tens of thousands
of trucks and the packaging and all the
rest of it that is how this problem will
get solved so I say we go we invite
these CEOs to be part of this and and
urge them to take it seriously and to go
far
maybe even faster than their completely
comfortable doing but that's I think
what we have to do not to defame you
know denounce before we've at least had
the serious conversation about it's time
your employees want to do this your
customers want to do this your investors
increasingly want to do this let's do
this that's our hope and and the
wonderful thing about companies the size
of Amazon or Walmart when they did it is
that they have a huge trickle up effect
because when Jeff Bezos came out and
said I'm gonna make Amazon climate
neutral by 2040 Paris agreement says
2050 of course he wants to do everything
better than that
so 2040 is for Amazon well good you know
we're gonna keep him to it now the
amazing thing about that is that in
order for Amazon to be climate neutral
by 2040 they have to work with all their
supply chain going up they have to work
with all of those companies that deliver
services and goods to them for them to
also be climate neutral ASAP because
otherwise they can't meet their own
commitment so borage companies are
actually very very key and instrumental
to this because it's not just about
their footprint it's about the embedded
footprint that they inherit in their
supply chain and the transformation of
that is really huge last question my
name is jackie with now this news and
every day I work with young climate
activists like the ones we've heard
today but when we do stories on them you
know including Greta Thun Berg icy
fierce criticism that they face and
largely it's because of a generational
gap I don't know if you're familiar with
the phrase ok boomer but it seems it
seems like there's a lot of guilt or
accountability that some are looking for
and on the other end we're looking at a
lack of education or just ignorance on
the issue so what is your advice to
young people to respond to that
criticism to foster constructive
conversations we should probably ask
them
oh hi thank you for your question come
come
[Applause]
it is true that we increasingly face
criticism and it's not only when we
speak to people with climate deniers or
things like that but also on social
media is as much as a tool to spread
information and organize her strikes and
get the information out there but it's
also a tool for people who want to
undermine us to personally attack us and
the way in which we stay resilient is in
to where when we build community with
each other when we organize we mimic the
world we want to see there is no
hierarchy in our organizing we are all
working towards the same goal
constructively choosing our passions
towards you know making the strike the
best it can be we got 300,000 people
striking in New York we put together a
whole concert people called it climb
cella
I was great but the point is that it's
not going to stop us the criticism is
not going to stop us and even though we
know that we are kids and we are not
here to tell you all the solutions that
there already are out there we are going
to do it because every kid who cares
about the climate crisis is going to
grow up to study through an
environmental lens and through change
and to change the world through that so
we are here to tell you personally
climate activists that I know don't use
okay boomer because we strive for
intergenerational cooperation and I
think that blaming and divided dividing
each other is not going to get us
anywhere which is why we don't use it
and I don't think it should be used and
I actually want to thank everybody who
is doing something because action
inspires action and you inspire us and
we're glad that we inspire you as well
Wow there is there is no there is no
there is no better note on which to end
this thank you
[Applause]